في المقابل انتقدت الخارجيه الصينيه
تصريحات واشنطن وطوكيو التي تقول ان
الصينا هي التحدي الاستراتيجيه الاكبر في
المنطقه واداع المتحدث باسم الخارجيه
الصينيه
كلا من الولايات المتحده واليابان الى
التخلي عن ما وصفها بعقليه الحرب البارده
واليابان على التخلي عن عقليه الحرب
البارده والتحيز الايديولوجيه والتوقف عن
خلق اعداء وهميين والتوقف عن ادخال عقليه
الحرب البارده في منطقه اسيا والمحيط
الهادئ والا تعمل
في المنطقه
حول هذا الموضوع تنضم الينا الان من
واشنطن مراسلتنا بيسان ابو كويك ومن
بيجينا مراسله الجزيره شيماء جوي اي ارحب
بكما ابدا بك بيسان نذكر ربما بدايه بما
خلصت اليه المحادثات اليابانيه الامريكيه
حتى اللحظه وما الذي نتوقع بخصوص قمه
اليوم هل نتوقع مناقشات نشطه
[موسيقى]
والحوار وهذا اللقاء المشترك ما بين
الرئيس الامريكي ورئيس الوزراء الياباني
سيركز بشكل اساسي على هذا التهديد الذي
تمثله الصين في المنطقه كما سمعنا من
التصريحات المتكرره من الاداره الامريكيه
ومن الجانب الياباني اضافه الى ذلك همم
التهديد او ربما المتمثل السعاده كوريا
الشماليه همم بعض
التجارب الصاروخيه التي تقوم بها في هذه
في تلك المنطقه طبعا ربما ابرز ما همم جاء
وربما
ايضا على هذه المحادثات
اللقاءات المشتركه بين وزيري الدفاع
البلدين وزيري خارجيه البلدين وذلك البيان
المشترك حول الاستراتيجيه
او الدفاعيه المشتركه ما بين الولدين
واعلان الولايات المتحده همم تعزيز وتحديث
وضعيه قواتها وتموضعها همم خصوصا في
اوكيناوه
والتركيز على تموضع مرن ومحدث
وقابل همم يتطوع مع الظروف المحيطه هناك
خصوصا في ظل هذا القلق المشترك ما بين
البلدين من التحركات الصينيه وايضا او
سيتم مناقشه وتم مناقشه ايضا خلال هذه
المحادثات الدفاعيه المشتركه طبعا ربما
تعزيز القدرات المضاده دي همم السفن في
تلك المنطقه لذا محادثات اليوم
ستبني على ما تم التوصل اليه خلال الايام
اليومين الماضيين من محادثات ثنائيه ما
بين مسؤولي البلدين همم وعلى الارجح سيكون
هذا هو الشق الدفاعي هو الذي سيطر على تلك
المحادثات
شيماء ماذا في الموقف الصيني الذي يبدو
وكانه لا يستوعب هذا او هذه المخاوف من
اليابان والولايات المتحده
تتهم كلا من واشنطن
وتوكيو بي محاوله لخلق اعداء وهميين في
المنطقه
بين وزيري همم الدفاع
والخارجيه الامريكيه
واليابانيه وقال ان يتحدث باسم الخارجيه
الصينيه خلال افاده سحر الصحفيه اليوم بان
مثل هذه الشركات الدفاعيه بين واشنطن يجب
ان تصب في مصلحه تعزيز الامن والاستقرار
في منطقه اسيا والمحيط الهادي وان لا تكون
في محاوله لمواجهه اعداء وهميين كما وصفها
هذا المصطلح ايضا تم استخدامه خلال
اليومين الماضي وذلك من خلال المتحدث
الصينيه الاتحاد الاوروبيه الذي نقل رساله
اتفاق بين الاتحاد الاوروبي ودول حلف
النيدو والذي جاء فيه ايضا بان الصين تمثل
اكبر تحدي الاستراتيجيا في المنطقه خلال
الوقت الراهن الصين ايضا عبر البعثه
الصينيه لدى الاتحاد الاوروبي عارضت بشده
ونددت مثل هذه الاتهامات قالت بانها عاريه
عن الصحه وقالت ايضا بان السنه لا يمكن
انت الا ان تكون همم شريكا متعاولا
اقتصاديا وتجاريا وحتى سياسيا وعسكريا
وقالت بان السن لا تطمح لان تكون عدوا لاي
دوله اخرى كذلك تم استخدام همم كلمه
التحيز الاديولوجي من قبل البعثه الصينيه
الاتحاد الاوروبي واتهمت الصين بان دول
الاتحاد الاوروبي ودول حلف انيته
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه بالاضافه الى
اليابان يحاولون وضع الصين في زاويه او في
مربع لانها دوله عدوه قالت لانها ابعد عن
ذلك واكدت ايضا الخارجيه الصينيه اليوم
بانها حاول العمل على اعاده العلاقات
الامريكيه الصينيه الى مسارها الصحيح بحسب
وصفهها
موصول بسان ابو كويك من واشنطن